of all rides in all the Disney parks
what would you make into a movie I
assumed uh parts of the Caribbean movie
would be bad where would you have gone
with Pirates Oh obvious where you go
with pirate okay go on
[Music]
brought to you by t-mobile
now Netflix has included another reason
why t-mobile is America's best unlimited
network hey welcome to the show
are you excited max is excited we're
going to talk about Disney liaison
scripts and scripts based on Disneyland
rides just like the Space Mountain
script that you yourself wrote right
yeah that yeah and I'm gonna talk about
it right now okay my Space Mountain
movie was cool it was it was a fifties
retro future movie they had rocket ships
and Reagan's but no cell phones or
Internet the rocket ships didn't run on
like a roller coaster track they did the
space mountains took you through tracks
and it was the only way you could move
faster than light that's great but like
was like rickety you've just got a waist
belt and you're like I'm gonna fall out
no I wanted to do that no the thing on
Space Mountain you're tall are you sure
standing pretty I assume there's a
puppeteer behind it's great noise oh my
god Frank yeah Uncle Frank
yeah you worked at Disney so you maybe
have done this but when I was writing
Space Mountain one of the main lights on
they let me ride it with lights on where
I am and it's you have no idea how high
up you are yeah well at the beginning of
that ride I always thought Space
Mountain was like small but you're like
2-1 defeat me yeah I was surprised by
the horizontal space it's like a
rectangular warehouse yeah where is it
going where's the cylinder it's so the
whole your whole idea of the space
you're in is completely wrong and
controlled by the ride yeah which is why
they've like fans and they have like all
right I like the meteor that you can
only see with the lights oh my god that
meters so lame but it's so right you
know it's there yeah it up with like a
purple light well the fact that they
haven't improved Space Mountain in any
in really any other way other than
changing the music to worse music do you
remember the surf music on Space
Mountain I think so the dick tail like
found one in Bangalore yeah that's what
inspired my movie was I wanted to do a
movie where like people said gee whiz
but the stakes were like still huge okay
and the robots they have like robots but
none of them work and so we have the big
tool bar
cylinder Bonnie coffee and it goes
handing coffee coffee got it had a cool
thing in it which is the idea that when
you come back from Lightspeed you're
nine and a half grams lighter but you
seem normal and then slowly over the
course of like a day it turns out that
the human soul can travel at light speed
so whole ships come back with people
with no souls who are still acting like
themselves but then they turn into these
horrible monsters no wonder this movie
didn't get made but there was this
really cool mission to my concept it's
one of the more straight wait a second
why Pirates of the Caribbean was about a
skeleton ship and you just did exactly
that
it wasn't the way I executed it when you
go to the Big Thunder Mountain with the
zombie Cowboys that roll into town that
would actually be a problem that's
actually the story of actual Big Thunder
Mountain is that it's a ghost train that
rolls through a ghost town I've always
wondered this like if Big Thunder
Mountain is a ghost town why isn't there
more like spooky they were like a ballad
that was about the ghost story that they
were gonna play in the queue yeah I
think it was too scary for kids I have
heard this yeah it's on YouTube also the
fact that Pirates went in the direction
it did is so mystifying because when I
saw pirates I assumed a parts of the
Caribbean movie would be bad and then by
the time we got to like they're jingling
the keys for the dog I was like this
movie is very good I know great and so I
went into Dead Man's Chest going this
movie will also be very good and it just
slowly was so bad why not just do
stories that peripherally use that
universe like why wasn't Pirates at an
expanded universe from the get-go why
was everyone dying what happened to
Norrington stand down what was he was
cool he dies for no reason
where would you have gone with pirates
Oh obvious where you go with pirate okay
go on second movie a totally new cast
totally new story about pirates midway
through the movie Jack Sparrow shows up
why is the rum gone and
and third movie new set of characters
near the end of the first act will
Turner shows up how did you get in
see temples from the second movie show
up with Jack Sparrow because they're
still on that adventure and build it
that way yeah because it's not called
Jack Sparrow of the Caribbean okay oh my
gosh what I want is a tiki room movie
more than anything because I love the
Tiki Room okay your action what would be
the politics of the Tiki removing I love
it because you've got like those Tiki
gods that are like out in the they call
it the lanai the outside um I love that
the birds are like these gods hate the
bird hate those party birds and they're
literally just like stupid congenial
party birds and like oh the gods are
angry again and it's like they don't
care did you see don't you see the
version of the ride when like the work
is so annoying did you hear where they
ended that no there was a mysterious
fire in the ceiling right and all the
birds were fine except diago and Zazu ha
I wonder if an employee's that thought
you think there's a a deliberate Akash
okay so this is that's a good transition
of all the rides in all the Disney parks
what would you make into a movie
absolutely Matterhorn really absolutely
yeah everybody was in the 70s yeah I
think I'd love to do a Matterhorn movie
because I would love to do a movie about
a mountain climbing expedition that gets
stranded in a mountain and finds like
the lost city of the yetis and like do
they have a city the yetis will
originally neighboring servants but
something went wrong a long time ago and
now they've taken it over so you have
wonderful we've read rendezvous with
Rama one of the coolest moments in the
book where there's this giant space
thing coming towards Earth and we go out
to meet it let me go inside of it and
inside of it is a city that's empty
thanks that's creepy it's so creepy and
great but I would love to do rendezvous
with Rama in the Swiss Alps you've got I
have them going around in Spa in yeah of
course no of course there's a hole to
bother you integrate the Skyway it's not
part of the matter anymore the Skyway
was such a bizarre thing because it was
like an invitation to throw things at
people below I know and jump on grad
night the people how many people died on
the Skyway I think one maintenance
worker was accidentally swept off
platform when it was turned on most of
the people died on the People Mover
well they didn't understand how
dangerous yes okay so they understand it
moves in a train and they were just
crushed
yeah when it would go through the
tunnels and smoke joints and there would
be Disney employees whose eyes were used
to the darkness and people would light
up joints and Disney employees in the
60s and 70s would flick them out of
their mouths because they couldn't and
they couldn't even see the guy coming
yeah like I can smell my doing like or
the two people would be making out in
some tap tap like that yeah
they don't do that anymore one of my
favorite memories of Disneyland is
walking along and I was like 15 I was
with this girl I was dating and you know
when you're like 15 and you get to be
alone with someone for the first time
you look alone with the person you're
dating and you're like we're like many
adults and no one's telling us where to
be there will only forever but I I
totally empathize with what you're
describing so we were walking and she
goes is that John Travolta and I look in
John Travolta's on the balcony of couple
up 33 with a cigar okay standing looking
at Disney we're like a plan tonight
closer and he said he's like this like
and and we didn't know what club 33 was
he was just talked about maybe he lives
above Pirates of the Caribbean yeah and
we were like that is John Travolta and
it was really funny because more and
more people saw me and her just staring
at him he was an attraction a sort of
drug to me yeah well John Travolta Ryan
he's never he never looked at the people
folks he was working at Tom Sawyer's
Island offensive like captain on a ship
Express that's amazing it was bizarre
memories and then eventually we got
tired of looking at just looking at his
eyes he was not bored he is still going
if you think it was like great memories
of mr. Lincoln looking to John Travolta
animatronic
if you could any of the EPCOT rides oh
if you could do any of the Epcot rides
as a movie what movie would you be most
interested to see I would I would go
deep cut I would go horizons which is
not there anymore
but it was like a Pirates of the
Caribbean stage did you go on horizon I
think it cause before I was born all of
the cool stuff 82 Epcot I want to go
there thank you
you're about Disney especially in Disney
World I did I got to do and it's weird
because aizen's is the best yeah it's
been closed forever
yeah I think it closed in like which was
the one where you got to choose your
ending that's right which Reacher and
it's like screens we can go to the
underwater city or the farm
okay so futures I remember vividly
because I had never encountered anything
like that and so I was on the ride just
experiencing the future and then the
thing came up was like choose what you
want the ride to do like I was like I've
got better than busy which one did you
pick underwater wind of course but I
thought I did I think I did all of them
alright and this was a great
conversation about okay bye max bye
why no that was good that was gold no no
it's time to hear from the comment
section you stay there
who's our first comment or oh it's Eric
Wagner vegged nur and he said you broke
character there with a smile Jenny there
is no character Eric when I smiled in
that episode that was the first time I
ever felt joy so what you see is what
you get I don't know why everyone keeps
saying it's a character your character
is so good but then a couple of times
when you spoke in your real voice with
the British accent I was like so
startled next comment is from crash and
CERN who said max seems nice but he
really didn't add anything to the show
it's about you
yeah it's cuz I wasn't on it that's
lucky I just seem nice but I didn't add
anything because I wasn't on it I
disagree I think that's an unfair
representation max doesn't seem nice
last comment is from Donnie Baker Donnie
Baker said this is wasting my time okay
those were some good comments I hope you
loved that episode because that was the
finale of season 1 so you're gonna be in
a dry spell for a while I'm gonna go
away to live in exile and a cave on Knox
tow and if you need me I'll leave a map
so leave some nice comments below and
maybe someday I'll return so bye bye bye
[Music]